[Music]
let's go out to proo youah and talk to
Dear Marie what's up
Marie hey how's it going we're partying
what's up what are you up
to oh thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it of course what's
happening um so my husband has seemed to
have a change of I don't know if you'd
call them values but like I guess values
over the past couple years um and I'm
just I don't know how to like respect
him and his views and still hold true
what's important to
me
yikes so give me some insight what is he
what is
he I mean this sounds like you are at
the edge here like what is what has he
changed his values on oh I feel
like I mean it's like little things like
um I'm a pretty conservative person and
so like swearing has never been like an
awesome thing for me and so it's little
like I know a lot of conservatives just
swear like like Sailors you you don't
like swearing and he didn't and now he
does and now he does and then but then
it escalates to the way we're parenting
we have four kids together and so then
it's like he thinks it's completely fine
for a six-year-old to
watch like PG-13 movie or things that I
feel like are too violent or things like
that and he thinks it's fine and so like
it's just there's a wide range of things
what are one or two that are driving you
like scaring you making you
uncomfortable
um well I think um we both grew up in
the same religion and now he's
having um I I don't he's he still
somewhat believes but he also likes to
say that I've been brainwashed Okay and
like the way he speaks about it to me
um but yeah I just I he felt I don't
know I don't know he's he says he's
always been an angry person and for a
long time he's tried to
like not be that way but I kind of
almost feel like he's slipping into
well this is just me and it's okay and I
almost kind of like it and so I think
that's one of the things that are
scaring me the
most is he becoming
abusive um I wouldn't say physically but
like there are like emotionally some
stuff that's happening that I don't love
give me an example of
it um he he Cur is like a sailor right
and and
so before it was always um he would do
it occasionally like if he were to hurt
himself working or doing something right
um and then it changed to instead of
calling an an objects those names he
turned it on to me and so now I'm
getting called those things have you
have you
said you will not curse at me in my
home yeah I've tried what does he what
does he say to
that he I he almost kind of takes it as
a
challenge like well what are you going
to do about
it I have something in my guts Maria
that tells me there's something deeper
here because I I'll just be honest I've
had periods of my marriage of 21
years when I completely walked away from
my childhood Faith walked away
completely my wife has had Ser Seasons
when what she believes now is radically
different from what she believed when
she was
married yeah and both of us have loved
being a steady partner for the other
person while they're reconsidering
things learning new things leaning on
doubt leaning on conviction all those
things but at no point has it ever
turned to me verse
you right and that's what I don't that's
what I don't love about the situation
and like I know that sometimes I haven't
handled things perfectly but I still
just feel like there's no hold on if you
ask your husband do not swear at
me and he then fires up a bunch of swear
words and says what are you going to do
about
it that's a power
Flex
right and that rarely happens in a
vacuum yeah that's a dude that looks
down on his wife with disdain she is
beneath him she's not a person to be
respected I wouldn't do that to a I I
swear too much okay like I run my mouth
too much but also I try my best to be
respectful yeah and even when Kelly's
like hey can you just chill on the
diarrhea jokes yeah absolutely I mean
depending on where we
are right you see what I'm saying it's
not like oh you wait now just that's
just dumb it's just
disrespectful right and so that's
contempt that is a relationship
that's be being held together by string
and duct
tape
right
what's the deeper issue
here is he seeing somebody
else no
no no I mean we we definitely have don't
have enough time to get to all the
issues but no there's other things going
on and okay I I don't know so how can I
help I just I want to know how to
to not feel like we're fighting about
everything like I feel like our views
are so opposite on most things and I
just I want views are not the problem
views are not the
problem it's the respect by which you
treat each
other that's the
problem I've got very few of my closest
friends share my specific faith
in the way that I believe
it yeah very very few of my friends
follow up and down with my political
beliefs very few if
any ideological
beliefs beliefs about love and care and
marriage very very
few but the way we engage each other and
the way I respect them and the way they
respect me guides
everything right and I think that's a
great fallacy of the culture we live in
now which is you have to believe every
single thing I do exactly the way I
believe it I think that's nonsense it's
not
real but we do have to be like
respectful human beings and treat each
other with
dignity otherwise we're children we're
children and so I don't think it's a
matter if you'll have different beliefs
it sounds like your husband's treating
you like
dirt and my question for you is why it
almost seems like you're giving him a
pass you're trying to make the problem
the beliefs and not
him well I can't do anything about
him but you can flip the lights on and
call a spade a
spade
ultimately here's the deal you have to
have an or what
statement when you get down to somebody
being super disrespectful or doing
things that you think hurt your kids
which if you are showing young children
violent movies you are hurting your kids
period if you're swearing at your kids
screaming and cursing at your children
or you're cursing at their mom in front
of them you're hurting your kids period
if you land
there if you're punching holes through
sheetrock I'm not hitting anybody okay
you're creating an environment where
everybody is terrified of what you're
going to do
next if every time Mom packs the kids up
and is going to church dad's sitting on
the couch making fun of Mom yelling at
mom you're so brainwashed you're such an
idiot then you have to make a
choice this is the bed I've made I'm
going to lay in
it
or here's my or what statement if you
you treat me like this again or scare
the kids like this again we are going to
leave and if you don't have an or what
statement then your husband's question
Rings true what are you going to do
about
it and that feels like it's closer to
home than you want to believe right
yeah
probably like at the very beginning of
this call you have a tone in your voice
that says you are about to walk out that
door and never turn around
once do you dream about that day
sometimes yeah sometimes
yeah can I tell you something you're not
a bad person for having that
thought do you have a place you could go
for a season for a couple of
days not
really you have a mom and a dad or a
sister or a cousin you could go stay
with for a while or a
girlfriend nothing local
that's fine doesn't have to be
local where are your tears coming from
are you mad at me and that's okay if you
are are you mad at him or are you is the
realization of the true reality that
live in starting to wash over
you or maybe all three no it's just yeah
it's just it's just hard yeah because we
go in these phases where we're
fine and we're
not but are you fine are are you fine
because you're playing
Peacekeeper
probably or are you able to drop your
shoulders and make your jokes back
let me ask you this do you have a friend
a girlfriend there in town that you
could sit down and go have coffee with
and just put all this on the table and
tell the
truth
yeah would you consider doing
that
I don't know there's something about
saying it out loud in the physical
presence of somebody else that
crystallizes it and makes it real and
sometimes it shakes us out of our
stuper because you spend a lot of your
life numb and a lot of time in your own
head don't
you yeah yeah God you deserve a a
different kind of life than that
maray you deserve to be loved and
cherished and challenged and you and
your husband never have to believe the
same things but y'all do have to treat
each other with respect and you deserve
laughter and rambunctious sex even
though you have four kids for God's sake
you like you are worth all that fun
building things planning for things
having people over your worth all
that and it just feels like you have
stucked like stuffed you so far
down in a in a sock just to keep the
peace inside your own
home is that like my only option
like de out and ultimate
I don't think that's go over well of
course it's
not it's not supposed to go over well
it's supposed to keep you safe and
whole if you tell me that my first
thought would always be we're going to
get out of the house change the
environment and go somewhere
preferably over a meal where we can go
slow and
talk and you for the first time can be
fully 100% honest if and only if it's
safe it's not safe then you can't do it
you're going to get
hurt either physically or emotionally or
both or if the kids are going to pay the
price for your
honesty then you have to get a therapist
you have to get a professional and you
have to walk that route but if you
haven't done that and you take your
husband out and say
hey when we got together we both
believed this we both believed this we
both believed this and over the last few
years things have changed cool people
change Ester Perell says most adults
have three to four or five great loves
in their lifetime and if they work
really hard it's with the same
person I love that I'm a very very
different person than the woman than the
the woman than the man my wife married
several times over that's awesome but if
you could tell your husband hey you've
changed I've changed our whole life is
different because we got four kids and
now that we've got four kids we're
butting up against some different
beliefs I don't believe six-year-olds
should watch violent
movies it really makes me feel gross
when you curse and yell at
me makes me feel unsafe and
scared I'm just picturing myself my wife
taking me out and telling me those
things I would want to crawl under the
table I'd be so ashamed of myself and I
would commit then and there to never do
that
again but if you've done that and your
husband's response is what are you g to
do about
it then yeah you may be an ultimatum
stage and if you think he's going to
hurt you you think he's unsafe then you
have to get some professionals in your
area whether it's the police whether
it's a licensed therapist whether it is
some sort
of other person in your life to have
some of those conversations
with because the alternative is your
four kids growing up in a house and they
think this is what love is and this is
what safety
is this is how husbands treat
wives and let's make no mistake I read
the data right are you working
full-time yeah I
am' be really scary to be a single mom
with four kids wouldn't
it yeah for sure yeah both economically
practically professionally it's a
nightmare so I'm not saying any of this
is
easy I'm just saying I'm sick to my
stomach for you and I wish so much
better for you
what are you
thinking I don't
know I tried we tried counseling for a
little bit and I just I wish we could go
back to it but things started to
get honest and he decided he didn't want
to go back
so so he chose his
comfort and he CH chose his fantasy
world
over a United healed
marriage that's what it feels like
that's not what it feels like hun that's
what it
is and I'm so sorry for you I'm
heartbroken for
you
I guess the other option here if you're
if you will convince me that you're safe
the other option here is is for you to
go see a counselor on your
own and begin to talk through I need
some new tools and some new skills so
that I can begin to defend myself stand
up for myself and ultimately make a
transition plan if that day
arises
I wish with all my guts I had better
news for you Marie but if you have a
partner who says I don't care what you
say oh yeah watch this you think that's
bad watch
this oh yeah you want you want to tell
the truth in the counseling session well
then screw you I'm never going
again these kids are a bunch of babies
they can watch that they're fine quit
being such a whiny brat you brainwashed
like dude you live in that
world I wish I had better news for you
man but that's a toddler you're married
to a
toddler who simply doesn't respect and
love his
wife you deserve more than
that and the path from where you are
right this second to being healed is a
treacherous and scary one make no
mistake so if you're my friend if you're
my sister if you're one of my buddy's
wives calling me your well if from my
buddy's wives That's a whole different
conversation I think it starts with
getting with a girlfriend and saying I
need to tell you some hard things and
some very deep things and my Pro I know
that you withheld on this call you
didn't tell me everything and that's
fine I totally understand that but you
sit down with a girlfriend you tell her
everything here's what we're going
through and I don't know what to do
next and call a coun and say Here's
everything I don't know what to do next
let's start at those two places and get
some people who live in your ecosystem
in your community around your family
let's get them speaking into
this but I think you deserve
more I think you deserve more and if
your husband wants to call into the show
I'd love to talk to him he won't but I'd
love to talk to him thanks for the call
Murray